hi there day 84.
um
basically a week ago
uh boy it's been a long haul but it's
it's i'm
very happy that i did it it's moved me
basically i've moved my korean from
where it was stagnating to where i feel
i have momentum i've moved it sort of
i'm over the hump
uh i'm thankful
to
my son mark for
basically
cajoling me into writing
writing is good i know writing is
important i know that when i learn
chinese i did a lot of writing but now
that basically i'm learning it out of
interest i'm kind of lazy so i focus
largely on listening and reading
and but the writing writing is good
especially if you have to deal with
different symbols it helps you in your
reading once you've actually written
these even doing it by hand but the
difficulty i had was
you know first of all i had to just
buckle down and learn it
and then as i said yesterday typing on
the computer because there's a keyboard
that pops up but then you have to with
your mouse go in and select each hungal
symbol to assemble the words
in order to write korean and that's a
lot of clicking with the most which is
tiring tiring on the hand tiring on the
elbow
however
the ipad and i did quite a bit of
writing today
the ipad is phenomenal
because not only do i only now point at
the hangul symbols with my finger which
is a lot easier
but because the ipad has this dictation
function
which is available in a number of
languages i've used it before for
english french spanish japanese chinese
so i can dictate in korean
and what comes out is it varies in
accuracy from
60 to 90 accurate
but now that i know how to type and i at
least yeah i know how to type how to
write with hangul more or less so i can
get in there and fix it up so because my
goal in the 90 day challenge is to have
3 000 words of writing submitted
and i haven't done anything yet
if i were to have to do that all
longhand so to speak poking at the
symbols on the keyboard i wouldn't get
there but i am hoping that now that i
can actually dictate it and then go in
and fix it up i'll be able to reach my
goal so for in the short term i'm still
just kind of
looking at where there are sentences in
english with the corresponding korean
then i try to type the korean and then i
check it against what's in the book so
it doesn't really require correction
because i can check it against what's in
the book but
perhaps tomorrow i'm going to actually
start
writing something my own thoughts in
korean which i'm going to submit for
correction at link
and so i mean the ipad it's it's so
valuable i can do uh i can look for
content on the internet i can uh do my
linking and check my my flash cards and
do everything on the ipad and it's a lot
more comfortable in many ways than
sitting at the computer so the ipad is
is truly truly amazing uh a week to go
so i'm gonna definitely try to put in
more
effort on my korean i've got i spoke
today to clara who is my korean tutor
who lives in paris and i've lined up
discussions with her for thursday sunday
and tuesday
and she doesn't have a webcam
but i've asked her if she can
find much he's going to try so that for
the final session on tuesday we can
actually have a live
session that i can record
and perhaps show you as sort of the
final
conversation in korean at the end of my
90 days i i don't uh i'm not going to be
fluent
but
as i say i feel very happy that i've
i've moved to where i can really enjoy
now reading kim jung-ha's podcast text i
still have trouble understanding it but
i know
that as i keep on going
uh i'll just get better someone asked me
i had an interview today with a fellow
from denmark who's going to put it up as
a podcast
i should have mentioned the name i'll
put it in the description here
um
but he said you know if you study so
hard like i said when i studied chinese
i studied seven eight hours a day and he
said well don't you start to forget
things if you do you know so much and i
said you don't forget things i mean you
do forget things but it doesn't matter
because stuff accumulates so i never
worry about what i forget in the short
term because i know that all of this
exposure is eventually going to settle
into my brain and i'll eventually be
able to use it and the same is true here
with this chemical i just have to i just
have to persevere
uh i
you know i'm gonna watch uh schuster
live again tonight as i said last night
it was fascinating had the politicians
from the west ukraine east ukraine
scenes from the barricades and
donyaska
and and high school children and and ah
it was very very
very suspense filled
uh
and informative and so i don't know what
he has lined up for tonight the problem
is i understand those who speak russian
those who speak ukrainian understand
less well
so i would like to get at ukrainian just
so that i can understand it better
and also you know if you learn ukrainian
now and i've learned czech and russian
then polish probably is a little more
accessible and i know a number of my
friends have visited poland and they
they just thought it was a great place
excellent food friendly people and so
forth
hi there
i had some
news site on and all of a sudden an ad
started playing so i had to shut it all
down
sorry about that yeah so um there you go
gonna focus on my korean
and uh going to continue the emphasis on
writing
and i do recommend that those of you who
learn
a language it's good to write there's no
question that is good to write i can
afford to be lazy but
it's it's good to write and i'm glad
that i'm writing so sometimes you need
to be pushed bye for now